it's Charles's first visit to Africa
since he became king after his mother
Queen Elizabeth II died last year he's
talked about things that she never did
the wrongdoings of the past are a cause
of the greatest sorrow and the deepest
regret there were abhorent and
unjustifiable acts of violence committed
against Kenyans as they waged as you
said at the United Nations a painful
struggle for Independence and
sovereignty 70 years ago people in
central Kenya having lost their Farmland
to British settlers rebelled against the
colonialists researchers say more than
990,000 people were executed tortured or
maimed when the British cracked down on
the rebels known as Mau many more were
detained in concentration
camps 10 years ago the British
government compensated about 5,000
survivors it's never admitted
responsibility and then
ever since Independence successive
Kenyan governments have kept close
relations with the UK including the
government of President William
Ruto many younger people on social media
and communities who lost their land say
colonial era injustices persist for days
a group of activists have tried to
demonstrate against Charles's visit
British atrocities and land grabbing
police have monitored them and stopped
them every
time down down so they held a conference
instead it is not enough to acknowledge
a painful PA unless he apologizes the
people have their reparations we have
back our land and the 6 million Acres
that are still under British are given
back to the people King Charles is
expected to visit several Community
projects and plant a tree before leaving
Kenya on Friday Malcolm Webb Al jazer
Nairobi make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer